direction maintenant les entrailles d'un
géant le pont Charles de Gaulle à Blois
et ses 412 m de long à 50 ans passés
l'ouvrage d'art le plus fréquenté de
Loir-et-Cher fait l'objet d'importants
travaux de renforcement un reportage
explication avec faustineau
c'est par une petite trappe située en
dessous qu'on pénètre à l'intérieur le
pont Charles de Gaulle à Blois est en
plein travaux depuis plusieurs mois mais
tout se fait à l'abri des regards
l'objectif renforcer l'ouvrage de 400
mètres de long par une technique de
précontrainte additionnelle pour bien
comprendre la précontrainte il faut
utiliser l'analogie de la pile de livre
si on appuie de plus en plus au milieu
de cette pile de livres et ben si on
veut garder un autre pile de rive droite
il va falloir qu'on augmente l'effort de
part et d'autre et c'est pour ça qu'on
rajoute ces câbles qu'on a le long de le
long des orages et donc ensuite on va
venir mettre en tension ces câbles pour
tout simplement rajouter cet effort
nécessaire au renforcement 17 ouvriers
sont en ce moment sur le chantier pour
installer les 106 km de toron qui
constitueront ces câbles une réflexion
sans laquelle le pont risquerait de
devenir un propre à la circulation on
avait effectivement constaté des
fissurations anormales sur le pont par
rapport à son mode de construction donc
les investigations ont permet
effectivement que ces fissures elle sera
évolutive dans le temps donc on aurait
effectivement un problème structurel
majeur sur l'ouvrage pour autant on
savait que voilà il y avait pas
d'urgence on ne mettait pas en péril on
va dire les usagers de cet ouvrage mais
qu'il fallait effectivement engager des
travaux de renforcement structurel
puisque à terme les fissures se serait
élargi une seconde étape de travaux qui
impactera davantage la circulation est
prévue à partir de l'été prochain elle
servira à refaire entièrement la
chaussée les trottoirs et l'étanchéité
du pont de nouveaux dispositifs de
sécurité seront aussi ajoutés c'est un
axe majeur assez 50 000 véhicules jours
c'est plus important que le trafic sur
l'autoroute sur la globalité ce sera 7
millions d'euros qui seront qui auront
été investis à terme sur cet ouvrage
pour permettre de lui donner 50 ans de
vie 50 années de vie en plus des 52 ans
qui a déjà le pont tout ça grâce à ses
travaux qui devrait se terminer au
printemps 2024